okay um can I ask you to put your pens
down and we're gonna launch from this
into well something semi new today and I
wanted to sort of make it slightly
memorable for you so I want to put your
pens out of your hands for minutes but I
want your concentration I want to bring
your minds back to a simpler time a
little while ago actually I want you to
have a guess have a think because I
don't just wear an apron for anything
right I would you have a guess as to
when you think a photograph like this
might have been taken have a think have
a think Australia is close but it's
actually before that it's Christmas
even before Christmas just just have a
closer look okay if you can see behind
me I mean either I don't have a very big
backyard and that's a big looking
backyard where does it look like I am so
think back think back about 12 months a
bit over 12 months actually are there
any politically minded yeah this is
thank you very much this is the federal
election so I was getting my my
democracy sausage on okay now I want you
to think about this situation because
it's going to be a little scenario for
us to have a think about why we're about
to do with this is not just like
interesting it's not just something we
can do it's actually something immensely
useful okay my kids primary school
there's one of the many that was hosting
voting and therefore was trying to raise
funds using a barbecue right so we have
this question for ourselves which is if
we want to try and increase profit
through this sausage sizzle we have some
choices that we can make about how we
run this sausage sizzle right we can
increase or decrease our profit by
virtue of the choices that we make and
there's a very simple choice that we
have all control over when you're
running a barbecue like this which is
how much you're going to charge right
now I will leave questions about who
you're going to charge what to another
point let's just say for the sake of you
know being a violent area we're gonna
charge over the same thing but I hope
you can see that as you change the
amount and we're gonna explore this in a
second as you change the amount that you
charge per sale you're going to
amount of profit that you've got you
agree with that have a think about this
for a second
okay I've got a vertical axis here and
got the horizontal axis somewhere near
the middle I hope you can see that if
for example I charged nothing personage
what's going to happen to my profit it's
gonna be yeah what profit is a good way
to say it it's gonna be it's gonna be
negative do you see that why is it
negative I'm in debt because I had to
pay money to buy the bread to buy right
and then and then I didn't make any
money back
to offset that right make sense okay but
a certain point if I increase as we go
to the right if I increase at a certain
point I make zero profit what we call
that by the way who studies economics
here this isn't it this is the
break-even point thank you okay so it's
like at some amount by the way what
would you guess it is I'm just curious
what you think just to break even not to
make any profit
how much anything you go to sell one
sausage one piece of bread two dollars
really who's bought us a loaf of bread
recently none of you okay so loaf of
bread cost what a dollar 27 it's got
like 20 slices in it so click 6 cents
for the bread 6 cents for the bread I
mean you got a sausage I reckon will is
pretty cool you said 50 cents right
somewhere around there it was just I
haven't put any numbers in here
intentionally cuz I doubt you don't know
the numbers yes but for everything that
I buy I'm gonna sell it for the same
amount that I bought it for right just
I'm just trying to illustrate yeah oh
don't worry my business is coming ok so
so clearly I don't want to just break
even right so if I increase what I sell
for then I'm going to make more profit
this makes sense of course right but but
here's where I'm getting to you right at
a certain point as you keep on raising
prices your profit starts to level out
right in fact I'm gonna argue that it
doesn't just level out I actually think
if you start charging too much you start
making less profit can you give me a
suggestion as to why
like I I think it comes way earlier I
want you to have a think right at what
point would you walk past a sausage and
you're like that's six place see if I'm
not buying that anyone having it passed
two dollars fifty well you have a lower
threshold okay
I actually think pseudo species very
common but maybe you like I see two of
those fifty I don't have like fifty
cents right yeah what do you think
okay okay and then there's like more
complicated questions like does it
include onion you know are they generate
all the rest right and then I'm gonna
say actually at a certain point it just
completely drops off because you're like
this is ridiculous this is extortion I
don't care about democracy does it right
okay
well if you make your pretty few raise
your price so high that no one buys then
you've you've had to pay to get all the
stuff and then you haven't yeah right
no no no this is it's not our time it's
not our time this is about how much we
charge for each one right it's a two
hundred dollar sausage okay
all right so I wonder if your brain is
connecting what we've been doing over
the last a while with this situation
okay because what we're wanting is to
get to this spot at the top right that's
where like this is my ideal situation
but we have a name for this right we
would call this a it's a station about
not just any stationary point it's a
it's a maximum it's a maximum Tory point
thank you okay so we're trying to find
this maximum turning point so calculus
here can help us write situations or I'm
not just you know silly ones like this
I'm operate like this you can change one
thing and it affects you go up and then
you're like oh now you want to go down
or vice versa maybe you want to minimize
something right you want the lowest
number of infections when you come up
for a rally or something like that right
you do all these kinds of things to try
and affect your situation okay so this
category of problems is called an
optimization problem because we're
looking for an optimal solution what's
the amount charged to get to the maximum
amount of money
okay now we're gonna do a little bit of
theory today because these problems are
very much like they're going to use all
the knowledge that we've developed over
the last couple of weeks but there's two
key differences you might want to jot
these down okay I'm the heading your
optimization okay in addition to
everything we already know about
calculus number one because these are
actual situations right because these
are actual situations sometimes like
it's not just some random here's an
equation off you go find me stationary
points and all the rest because these
are real situations sometimes there are
real constraints that act upon the
situation that give you some kind of
limitation I'll give you an example
right now just look up for a second okay
you may have a situation where for
instance you can't just charge whatever
you want you might only be allowed to
charge within a certain range for
example this is a hyper example but if
you are running a Bunny's barbecue you
can't just charge you know I'm gonna
charge 10 bucks or 50 cents right they
actually are very stringent about how
much you can charge right so there may
be constraints that make you say okay
you're only allowed to charge this much
so therefore you have to change your
decisions right now have a look at my
situation here suppose this orange
section is where you're allowed to
charge okay it's like I'm going to
restrict your dollars per individual
sausage sale right in this case the the
stationary point is irrelevant isn't it
because it's above what you're allowed
to charge right so wouldn't it follow
that if what I'm looking for is the
optimal solution in this situation if
that orange section is all I'm allowed
to work within then the actual optimal
solution is not at the turning point
does that make sense it's what we call
an endpoint right because you know
that's where my situation ends it's like
it's a domain restriction okay um so
that's what I'm allowed to go so that's
the first difference so we're going to
talk about that in a second and then the
second difference is unlike in
situations where you just get handed
here's the equation off you go start
differentiating right often this thing
which we would call the model for your
situation you have to construct this
thing yourself you've got to create the
equation by looking at the situation and
like looking at the geometry of it or
looking at the situation like
I haven't given you an equation for this
thing I mean it looks kind of like a
problem but it looks like also weird and
wobbly a little bit less like a parabola
so you have to construct this thing and
that takes its own amount of thought
okay does that make sense